[Musique]
au Cameroun les conditions de vie ne
sont pas trop favorables et nous ce
qu'on a c'est notre art qui est le
breakdance et c'est grâce à ça que nous
avons pu arriver à cette étape parce que
le Cameroun a ses talent de toujours
pouvoir émerveiller
les jeunes les jeunes de la rue
[Musique]
grâce à la musique que nous oublions les
difficultés de la vie et aussi la danse
parce que les deux vont ensemble en tant
que danseur nous n'avons pas cette
chance au pays de pouvoir mieux nous
exprimer nous sommes nous sommes pas
délaissés mais nous n'avons pas des
opportunités alors quand on a une
occasion comme celle-ci nous sommes
obligés de prester et de continuer de
danser
[Musique]
mes parents me battaient tout petit
parce que je passais ma vie à aller voir
des grands frais danser les danses
traditionnelles donc c'est à partir de
là que j'ai aimé la danse et un matin
j'ai vu une vidéo de France sur le
breakdance je me suis intéressé et j'ai
commencé à pratiquer dans ma chambre
petit à petit et mon père voulait que je
sois footballeur et moi j'ai voté pour
certains et au fur et à mesure que le
temps passait j'ai compris que lorsqu'on
est passionné on peut branler les étapes
parce que je mange toujours avec moi ma
médaille d'or parce que je suis médaille
donc toujours je la garde parce que ça a
été un combat difficile et derrière moi
je porte une fado il y en a beaucoup
derrière qui compte sur moi et qui veut
que je les aide aussi avoir cette
médaille
[Musique]
lorsqu'on a pris la nouvelle franchement
nous avons nous les Cameroun nous avons
coulé les langues pensez actuellement
on sait que demain on représentera le
Cameroun j'ai ce rêve depuis tout petit
parce que je vois les choses olympiques
depuis longtemps je sais que demain
j'irai à cette compétition et je
travaille quand parce que comme je le
dis toujours
lorsqu'on a une passion on tient tête on
ne lâche rien quelle que soit les
conditions
[Musique]